the thing that i've always found amazing
about chemistry it's an entire field of
science that we as human beings have
developed to actually understand what is
happening at an almost unimaginably
small scale in particular we're going to
be thinking about the atomic and even
the subatomic scale and by looking at
that scale we can then begin to
understand the universe in which we live
in the scale in which we live in and
even be able to make predictions about
what will happen and make things that
are useful for for human beings
so if we're going to operate at this
small of a scale and we're going to
appreciate in a few seconds how small of
a scale it is we're going to have to
have some units of measurement and this
video is going to focus on
mass how do we measure mass at such a
small scale
well to do that the chemistry community
has historically used something called
an atomic mass unit i'll write it here
atomic
atomic
mass
unit
and it's historically denoted as amu
and more recently the more modern
version of this is the unified atomic
mass unit that is denoted by just a u
instead of an amu
so how does a unified atomic mass unit
connect to our units of mass that we
might use on a larger scale like say
grams or kilograms
well the unified atomic mass unit is
defined as
1.6605
four zero times ten to the negative
twenty seven
kilograms
so when you see something like this you
might have a few reactions your first
reaction which would be an appropriate
reaction is that wow 10 to the negative
27 power is very small to appreciate it
you could write it out it would be zero
point and then 26 zeros and then you
would have one six six zero five four
zero so very very very small really
unimaginably small we can only try to
abstract it with things like mathematics
the other thing you might appreciate is
like this feels like a bit of a a hairy
number here one point six
zero
why did they define it that way
and the answer to your question is this
definition makes it a lot cleaner when
we think about the mass of whether it's
an atom or the constituents of an atom
like a proton or a neutron
roughly speaking the mass of a proton
is approximately one unified atomic mass
unit the mass of a neutron
is approximately
one unified atomic mass unit it actually
turns out that a proton is a little bit
more than one it's about 1.007
atomic mass units but it's approximately
1 and the neutron is actually a little
bit more than even a proton it's 1.008
approximately unified atomic mass units
now an electron's mass is actually far
smaller than either of these it's
actually almost 1 2 000 of a proton or
neutron and so you can imagine an atom
which is made up of protons and usually
neutrons and electrons as well the mass
is mainly going to be the protons and
neutrons in the nucleus and so if you
know the number of protons and neutrons
in the nucleus you're going to have a
pretty good sense of its atomic mass
and you can see that indicated on a
periodic table of elements which we have
here and we will study the periodic
table of elements in a lot more detail
in other videos but you can see a couple
of interesting elements one you have the
abbreviation of a given element h
represents hydrogen
the number on top on this periodic table
that's the atomic number and that tells
you how many protons it has and an
element is defined by the number of
protons so any atom that has exactly one
proton in its nucleus is going to be
hydrogen by definition
any atom that has exactly 20 protons in
its nucleus is going to be calcium by
definition any atom that has exactly 36
protons in its nucleus is going to be
krypton
by definition
so what would you expect the mass of a
hydrogen atom to be pause this video and
think about it
well we know that all hydrogen atoms by
definition have one
proton but it actually turns out there's
different versions of hydrogen that can
have different numbers of neutrons most
of the hydrogen in the universe actually
has zero neutrons
zero neutrons there are versions that
have one or two neutrons but most
99.98 percent roughly of hydrogen in the
universe has one proton zero neutrons
and if it's a neutral hydrogen it's
going to have one electron
and when we talk about versions of a
given element there's a fancy word for
it they're called isotopes and the
different isotopes they'll all have the
same number of protons because they're
talking about the same element but
they'll have different numbers of
neutrons
and so if this is the most common form
of hydrogen what do you think its mass
is going to be
well its mass is going to be essentially
the mass of a proton plus an electron
and roughly speaking it's going to be
the mass of a proton because the mass of
a proton is going to be so much larger
than the mass of an electron and so you
would expect that its mass is
approximately one
unified atomic mass unit now if you were
to precisely look at the mass of a
proton and a electron if you add them
together you actually get something
that's a little bit closer to 1.008
and you actually see that right over
here on the periodic table of elements
now this number although it is
pretty close to the mass of the version
of hydrogen that i just described it's
actually a weighted average of the
various versions of hydrogen it's just
close to this version because this
version represents most of the hydrogen
that we actually see around us
if for example you had two versions of
an element some hypothetical element and
let's say that eighty percent of the
element that we see is version one and
version one has a mass of let's call it
five atomic mass units
and then version two it's the remainder
twenty percent of what we observe of
that element it has an atomic mass of
six atomic mass units you would get a
weighted average here of 5.2
unified atomic mass units and that's
actually how
these numbers are calculated they are
not just the mass of
one type of that element their weighted
average mass of the various isotopes of
the various types and so this number on
a periodic table of elements is known as
the average atomic mass
average average
atomic
atomic
mass
now in older chemistry books and this is
actually the case when i first learned
chemistry they call this number atomic
weight and i've always complained about
it because it's really talking about
mass not weight if you don't know the
difference you will learn that at some
point in the future it's really talking
about average atomic mass now i'll give
you one little detail that might be
useful to you sometimes you'll hear
something called relative atomic mass it
actually turns out this periodic table
of elements because it does not write a
little u after each of these numbers
it's essentially these numbers are
unitless so it's really talking about
relative atomic mass so it's saying hey
on average for example the mass of a
carbon atom is going to be roughly 12
times that of on average the mass of a
hydrogen atom
if they put the units here then that
would actually truly be average atomic
mass but for our purposes as we go into
chemistry you can look at these numbers
and say okay if oxygen has a relative
atomic mass of 16 its average atomic
mass is going to be 16 unified atomic
mass units and as we will see in the
future this understanding of average
atomic mass will prove to be very very
useful